While everyone else is focused on other
stuff like Twitter spats, let's focus on
the real news, the developments in AI,
which I would say are accelerating.
Particularly if you are Google, who have
just released the latest version of
Gemini 2.5 Pro, fairly unambiguously,
the best language model in the world for
the majority of benchmarks. And yes,
including my own simple bench. It beats
out all other models including Claude
Opus 4, Grock 3, and OpenAI's 03. Though
we are expecting 03 Pro from OpenAI
fairly shortly. And that's before you
get to the fact that it's quicker to
respond. It's cheaper via the API. It
can ingest up to 1 million tokens.
That's four or five times more than
other models. Now, before we get too
hyped up though, there's a reason why
the CEO of Google Deepmind, Demis
Sarabis, responsible for Gemini and the
CEO of Google itself, Zundabachai,
yesterday both said that they don't
expect AGI before 2030. Now, I'm sorry
for those listening on the podcast, but
take a look at these two lines here. And
which two of these vertical lines would
you say is longest? Well, Gemini 2.5
Pro, the latest version 0605. Yes, if
you are not in America, that naming
scheme is incredibly confusing. But this
latest version, what do you think it
says? It says, "At first glance, line A
appears to be much longer than line B."
However, this is a trick of the eye and
they are the same length. In fact, later
on, the model doubles down by saying,
"You can test this yourself by placing a
ruler up against the screen. You'll find
they are identical in length." For those
listening, they are pretty obviously not
the same length. Now, of course, that is
anecdotal, but there is a reason why
Sundur Pachai said that in the near to
medium-term, Google will be hiring more
workers, not firing them. Of course, you
can't always trust CEOs, which is why
I'm going to dedicate the end portion of
this video to investigating all those
headlines you've been seeing recently
about a white collar blood bath. I found
that when you dig deeper, not everything
is as it seems. Now, somewhat strangely,
I want to start with an interview
released in the last 18 hours on Lex
Friedman with the CEO of Google, Sundar
Pachai, because the first half of this
video is going to be about Gemini 2.5
Pro. But that's not even the biggest and
best version of Gemini 2.5, which is
Gemini 2.5 Ultra, unavailable to
practically anyone. So, all these record
benchmark scores you're going to see,
this isn't even their biggest and best
model. Each year I sit and say okay
we're going to throw 10x more compute
over the course of next year at it and
like will we see
progress sitting here today I feel like
the year ahead we'll have a lot of
progress I think it's comput limited in
this sense right like you know we can
all part of the reason you've seen us do
flash nano flash and pro
models but not an ultra model it's like
for each generation we feel like we've
been able to get the pro model at like I
don't know 80 90% of ultra
capability, but ultra would be a a lot
more slow and lot more expensive to
ser. But what we've been able to do is
to go to the next generation and make
the next generation's Pro as good as the
previous generation's Ultra, but be able
to serve it in a way that it's fast and
you can use it and so on. the models we
all use the
most is maybe like a few months behind
the maximum capability we can deliver,
right? Because that won't be the
fastest, easiest to use, etc. But as the
latest version of Gemini 2.5 Pro is
apparently going to be a stable release
used by hundreds of millions of people
over the coming months, let's quickly
dive into those benchmark results. On
the right, by the way, you can see the
results of the three iterations of
Gemini 2.5 Pro. To be clear, the latest
one is what's going to be rolled out to
everyone in the coming couple of weeks.
On obscure knowledge, as tested by
humanity's last exam, it nudges out
other models. For incredibly challenging
science-based questions, it gets
86.4% when PhDs in those respective
domains get around 60%. On very
approximate gauges of hallucinations, it
scores better than any other model. And
on reading charts and visuals and other
types of graphs, it's at least on par
with 03, which is around four times more
expensive and a lot slower than Gemini
2.5 Pro. Again, it's worth highlighting
that Gemini 2.5 Pro is really the middle
model of the Gemini series. You may also
notice that the vast majority of these
record-breaking scores are on a single
attempt. We haven't yet seen the deep
think mode from Gemini 2.5 Pro. That
would be roughly the equivalent of the
multiple attempts or parallel trials
that some of the other models utilize.
As for coding, the picture is a lot less
clear. When you're talking about
multiple languages, Gemini seems to do
better, as judged by ADA's polyglot
benchmark. When you're talking about a
slightly more software engineering focus
like Swebench Verified, it seems like
Claude is still very much in the lead.
However, I will make a confession which
is that I was having an issue with
connecting a domain on Firebase, which
is Google on the back end. Now, this was
more to do with the app hosting
infrastructure, but you'd have thought
as a Google entity Firebase, that Gemini
would know the most about it. Now, I
won't show you the full 2-hour
conversation, but I basically gave up
with Gemini 2.5 Pro. This was in
fairness the May instance of Gemini 2.5
Pro, but Claude for Opus was able to
diagnose the issue almost immediately.
And I'm sure everyone who uses these
models for coding will have similar
anecdotes where the benchmarks don't
always reflect real world usage. But
while we are on benchmarks, what about
my own benchmark, Symbol Bench? Well, I
am going to make a confession, which is
that I thought the latest version of
Gemini 2.5 Pro, the one from yesterday,
would underperform. Why did I think
that? Well, because the first version of
Gemini 2.5 Pro, the one I think from
March, got
51.6%. But then when we tried the May
version of Gemini 2.5 Pro, it was really
hard to get a full run out of the model.
I talked about this on Twitter, but the
one run where agreed to actually answer
the question, I think it got around 47%.
So, I actually had a theory that I was
going to come to you guys and gloat and
be like, "Yeah, they're doing RL for
coding and mathematics, but that's kind
of eroding the common sense of the
models." This shows how Symbol bench
tests things that other benchmarks don't
capture.
Unfortunately, what actually happened is
that when we tested the very latest
version of Gemini 2.5 Pro yesterday
evening, we couldn't get because of rate
limiting a full five runs, which is why
we're not yet reporting the result. But
based on the four runs we did get, it
was averaging around 62%. So, my little
theory about RL maximization just
completely went out the window. No, but
seriously, even based on four runs, you
can see that performance is getting
better and better and better across all
model types. Hate to say it, but I
genuinely think Simple Bench won't last
much longer than maybe 3 to 12 months.
We've got to talk about those job
articles now, but if you want a bit more
of a reflection about the kind of
questions that Claude for and Gemini 2.5
Pro are now getting right, do check out
this video on my Patreon. Suffice to say
though that when we reach the moment
that there are no textbased benchmarks
for which the average human could beat
frontier models, we will have crossed
quite the Rubicon. Sundar Pachai and
Deisab, CEOs of Google and Google
DeepMind put the date of full AGI at
just after 2030. Then you see stuff
which obviously you know we are far from
AGI too. So you have both experienced
this simultaneously happening to you.
I'll answer your question but I'll also
throw out this. I almost feel the term
doesn't matter. What I know is by 2030
there'll be such dramatic
progress. We'll be dealing with the
consequences of that progress both the
positive externalities and the negative
externalities that come with it in a big
way by 2030. So that I strongly feel
right whatever we may be arguing about
the term or maybe Gemini can answer what
that moment is in time in
2030 but I think the progress will be
dramatic right. So that I believe in.
Now, please do let me take a moment to
tell you about a tool that's available
today and that yes can utilize a variety
of models including Gemini 2.5. That
would be the sponsors of today's video,
Emergent Mind, which I've been using for
around 2 years before they even
sponsored the channel. What it allows me
to do is just catch up on those trending
papers that I may have missed otherwise,
like this one. As you know, I read those
papers in full myself, but sometimes I
do miss a paper that is trending on
Hacker News or X. You can download these
summaries as a PDF in markdown or even
listen to it as audio. The 2.5 Pro
summaries are appropriately on the pro
plan, but anyway, link in the
description. Now, on jobs this week and
last, I've been seeing plenty of
articles like this one going viral on
Twitter and Reddit. Has the decline of
knowledge work begun? Asked the New York
Times. For one LinkedIn executive in a
guest essay on New York Times, it has
already begun with the bottom rung of
the career ladder breaking. Now,
obviously, I am one of the last people
to underestimate the potential of AI and
its impacts on the world of work. But
these stories were about what was
happening now, not what might be coming
in 3 to 5 years. So, I wanted to ask, do
they have any stats to back this stuff
up? A lot of the articles cross
reference each other, but the one stat
that they all seem to turn to is the
fact that the unemployment rate for
college graduates in the US has risen
30% since September 2022. Not risen to
30%, has risen 30%. That sounds pretty
ominous, right? But let me give you two
contextual facts. The first is that that
30% rise is from 2% to 2.6% for college
graduates. That's versus 4% for all
workers. So, a tiny bit less dramatic
when you hear it is 2.6%. Now, I can
just feel the rage building up among
some of you. So, let me just give you
one more contextual fact and then my own
thoughts because even though 2.6%
unemployment rate for college grads in
the US doesn't sound too dramatic, a 30%
rise is pretty real. So, I dug deep and
looked at the data source that these
articles were citing. And you can see it
here with the college graduates at well
now it seems 2.7%. That is the line in
red and it comes from March of this
year. But if we zoom out, we can see
that for example in 2010 it was 5% among
all college graduates. Even in what is
this
1992 it was 3.5%. Don't worry I am not
in any way downplaying the impact of
what's coming. I'm just saying it's a
bit much to say the impact is already
incredibly noticeable. Now, the other
article that went viral was this one.
Behind the curtain, a white collar
bloodbath, which heavily featured quotes
from Dario Ammedday, the CEO of
Anthropic. When the language is caveed,
like AI could wipe out half of all
entry-level white collar jobs over the
next 1 to 5 years, it's actually quite
hard to disagree. The way AI is
accelerating, it's really hard to
counter, say, a could scenario. Amade
gets on to slightly more dangerous
territory when he says most people are
unaware that this is about to happen.
Others at anthropic like Schulto Douglas
are even more definitive. There's
important distinctions to be made here.
One is that I think we're near
guaranteed at this point to have
effectively models that are capable of
automating any white collar job um by
like 2728 and or near guaranteed end of
decade. This topic obviously deserves a
full video on its own, but for me, the
necessary but not sufficient condition
for white collar automation would be the
elimination of hallucinations and dumb
mistakes that the models don't
self-correct. If there is even a 1%
chance that Frontier models of 2027 and
2028 make mistakes like this one, then
having a human in the loop to check for
those mistakes would surely allow for
massively increased productivity. Which
leads me personally to the whole calm
before the storm theory which I first
outlined on this channel in 2023. I said
back then that we would first see a
massive increase in productivity as
humans complement the work of Frontier
AI. That's why I don't think this white
collar automation will happen as Amade
says in as little as a couple of years
or less. Now I know what many of you are
thinking well these CEOs would know far
better than those of us on the outside.
But I remember almost 2 years to the day
Sam Orman saying and I quote, "We won't
be talking about hallucinations in 18
months to 2 years." That was on the
world tour that he did after the release
of GPT4. Well, almost exactly 2 years on
from that quote, we get this in the New
Scientist. AI hallucinations are getting
worse and they're here to stay. Among
other things, the article cites a stat
on a benchmark called simple QA, which
I've talked about before on the channel,
where basically 03, the latest OpenAI
model, hallucinates a bit more than
previous models. Then you guys might
remember those viral articles about Cler
eliminating its customer service team so
it could use AI instead. Now, very
quietly, without the same fanfare,
they've actually reversed on that
policy, saying that customers like
talking to people instead. After getting
rid of those 700 employees, it's now
rehiring many human agents. Duolingo,
the language app, also said that it was
going to rely on AI before backing down
and reversing that policy, hiring more
humans. Which leads me to the whole calm
before the storm theory. While frontier
language models are still weak at
self-correcting their own
hallucinations, the human can still
complement their efforts and lead to
overall more productivity. This leads to
limited effect on the unemployment rate.
I do know there are anecdotal examples
about people losing their jobs to AI.
Trust me, I am aware of that and I have
read those articles. But limited net
effect on the unemployment rate. This of
course leads to more and more investment
in AI and less and less regulation of AI
as countries try to win the AI race
socalled. But then there might come a
tipping point where models using enough
compute, having access to enough diverse
methodologies for self-correction
finally stop making dumb mistakes and
only miss things that are beyond their
training data. Of course, at that point,
and I've actually got a documentary
covering this, endless amounts more data
would be given to them through, for
example, screen recording, mass
surveillance, or robotics data. then the
complacency that might have set in
throughout the remainder of the 2020s
might be quickly upended. And to be
honest, it's not like blue collar work
would be immune from the effects of AI
automation for that much longer than
white collar work at that point. This is
the fully autonomous figure O2 robot
humanoid. So yes, I probably pissed off
those who expect imminent upheaval and
those who think LM are completely
overhyped, but there you go. That's just
my opinion of what is coming. While all
of this is going on, of course, we get
access to some pretty epic AI tools,
like the brand new 11 Labs V3 Alpha.
Hey, Jessica, have you tried the new 11
V3? I just got it. The clarity is
amazing. I can actually do whispers now
like this. Ooh, fancy. Check this out. I
can do full Shakespeare now. To be or
not to be, that is the question. Fun to
the lights here for this semi-final
clash. The stadium buzzing with
anticipation. 11 Labs United in their
iconic black and white shirts pushing
forward with intent straight from the
opening whistle. As has been the theme
of this video though, 11 Labs can't rest
easy because Google with their native
text to speech in Gemini 2.5 Flash isn't
that far behind. Hey Jessica, have you
tried the new 11 V3? I just got it. The
clarity is amazing. I can actually do
whispers now. Like this. Ooh, fancy.
Check this out. I can do full
Shakespeare now. To be or not to be,
that is the question. Hey, Jessica, have
you tried the new 11 V3? I just got it.
The clarity is amazing. I can actually
do whispers now like this. Ooh, fancy.
Thank you so much for watching. Let me
know what you think as always and have a
wonderful